- [Jim] As far as my resume,
you, you don't know me,
but you know Tigger and Winnie the Pooh.
[Jim as Pooh] I think it
goes something like this,
but I can only do it for a
small smackerel of honey.
[Jim as Tigger] And Tigger,
don't be ridicerous.
Tiggers are wonderful things.
Their tops are made out of rubber,
their bottoms are made out of springs.
You gotta pay for the
rest, I'm kidding with ya.
(Tigger's laugh)
(light upbeat music)
- [Jim] Well, you know, the
way I got into the industry,
I mean, I guess I was kind of
doing research my whole life
because I'd be sitting in
the back of the classroom and
(dolphin sounds) you know I thought it was
time to break out a dolphin.
I, I don't wanna say
I was the class clown;
I was the class wit
'cause it sounds better.
Some of the characters I
played as a voice actor:
[Jim as Razoul] I take my orders
directly from Jafar, Princess.
[Jim as Kaa] And all I want
you to do is trust in me.
[Jim as Ray] The women like
a man with a big back porch
some kinda yeah, whoo hoo!
[Jim as Pete] Come here
you little write-off.
- [Jim] People say, well,
which one's most like you?
And probably Darkwing Duck
'cause he's a wise guy.
[Jim As Darkwing Duck]
Well, I am the terror
that flaps in the night.
I am the bug that splatters
across the windshield of crime.
I am Darkwing Duck.
[Pooh] What could be more important
than a little something to eat?
- [Jim] Well you know as
far as performing Pooh,
You have to be true to the character;
I always say that Pooh sees the world
through honey-colored glasses.
Not a bad way to go.
(light uptempo music)
- [Pooh] Somebody or
something has found my honey.
- [Jim] I jokingly say
that I'm Winnie The Pooh
and the anti-Pooh, 'cause
I'm the Tasmanian Devil.
(wild sounds)
(laughs) Taz like.
(music crescendos)
- [Taz] (belligerent sounds)
- [Female Tasmanian Devil]
Having a little trouble?
- [Jim] A lot a times my agent
will get in touch with me,
and there'll be a special
needs little boy, little girl,
we're on the telephone,
and they're talking to Pooh or Tigger.
- [Jim As Pooh] Oh, hello there, Billy.
- [Billy] How are you?
- Jim as Pooh] Oh, very lovely.
- [Billy] Your Tigger voice.
- [Jim As Tigger] Oh, the colors,
tiggers are the wonderful things,
their tops are made of rubber,
their bottoms are made up of springs,
they're bouncing,
- [Jim] But his response
was, it's just so cute.
He's in the world, you
know Tigger was alive
and talking to him.
To know that you can
bring him into smileville,
and where everything's happy,
and you're, you know, it's
just a blessing and a half.
I never take it for granted.
Honestly, the most rewarding part is
seeing people's reactions
and hearing stories about how
this one song got them through tough times
and they, they'll go back
and they'll listen to "Wherever You Are"
a song that Winnie the Pooh sung.
- [Pooh] ♪I need you to
come here and find me ♪
♪ Cause without you I'm totally lost ♪
- [Jim] I'm grateful, grateful everyday.
(gentle upbeat music)